بين الوزراء وهرمل يعودان إلى الغرفة أيضاً
هذه المرة هذا صحيح، إنها بالفعل المرة الثالثة التي تتم فيها مناقشة الموضوع
وفي اليوم التالي، في مجلس الوزراء، وافق معظم الوزراء
تحديث وقارب أمني على القتال في المرحلة
مؤكداً رغم سهولة المناقشة بالنسبة للوزير
ديفيد أمسالم، الذي يجب الاعتراف به، ليس له منصب في الحكومة
والمدعو الشخصي لنتنياهو يخاطب الوزير باغانتس
ويبدأ بينهما جدال ينتهي أيضًا بإصابة رأسه
الحكومة تولي اهتماما للاقتباسات Asar Maslam التي أريدها
للإشارة إلى عار الأسبوع الماضي جاء هنا
وكأننا هاجمنا الحرمل فيك أنت الذي وزعت لا
أنا من تحدثت وأنت أيضًا سربت شيئًا ما
يمكنك طرح الأسئلة هنا في مجلس الوزراء، المشكلة هي
التسريبات هي أشياء لا ينبغي أن تخرج، وبالتالي لا تخرج
أفهم سبب صعوبة نقل صديقي
لقد وضعت الوزراء في جهاز كشف الكذب لختمهم
واجتياز جهاز كشف الكذب، نحن حقًا نصل إلى هناك
ليوم هذه الحرب كيف ترون
الطريقة التي تعمل بها الأشياء حقًا هنا هي أنا
انظر، لقد قلت بالفعل منذ شهرين ونصف
قلت إن كل يوم تستمر فيه هذه الحرب هو يوم جيد
إلى بيبي نتنياهو وحكومته لأنني في كل وقت
أسمع الحديث عن أنه بعد الحرب سنناقش كل شيء
وسنرى على من يقع اللوم، كان يجب أن يفعلوا ذلك منذ فترة طويلة
العودة إلى ديارهم وأعتقد كل يوم أنهم يجلسون
خطير على دولة إسرائيل وبيبي خطير على الدولة
إسرائيل سوف تأخذ هذه الحكومة التي سمعتها
والآن بعد أن تحدثت عن ميري ريجيف مع البامبا
التي فتحتها وقالت العرض يبدأ الآن شاهد
مرجعهم أو سماع السلام كيف
يتحدث عن كوبي ريختر كيف يجرؤ
للتحدث ضد الطيار الإسرائيلي البطل الذي قصف دوت
الطيران ومع الميراج في حرب الأيام الستة
كيبور أنه قاتل في الطائرات وأسقط الطائرات
الفاسي في سوريا هو من يستطيع حتى أن يتكلم
له على الإطلاق بهذه الطريقة التي تكلم بها الرجل
لقد بنى صناعة والآخر جلس هناك في مكتب في مكتب
الخزانة أو فيما بعد تحالف القدس ماذا فعل
بسبب الحالة، لم يقم حتى بعمل الاحتياطيات
لقد ثار جميع الاحتياطيات ضد القائد
شركته عار وعار أن ينهاروا
الدولة وليس لديهم خطة اليوم
البلاد أمامها فرصة تاريخية لن تتكرر مرة أخرى
مرة واحدة لنحدد ماذا سيكون في غزة وكيف سيكون في غزة
ولا يمكنهم أن يقرروا أن الجيش لا يفعل ذلك
اعلم أنه لا توجد صورة للنصر لسنا كذلك
يمكن العودة من هذه الخطوة دون المشاركة مرة أخرى
في إسرائيل، معنى ذلك هو أن الحكومة الإسرائيلية تحتاج
تقدم تقريبا كل ما هو معقول لا أحد
أعتقد أنني لا أعتقد أن ذلك ينطبق أيضًا على عائلات المختطفين
يقولون دعونا نوقف القتال لأنه سيكون كذلك
حقا فشل ذريع لكل الثمن الذي دفعناه
لا أستطيع أن أقول سنوار أنك فزت بإعادة
المختطفون سيبقون، ومن الواضح أن الأمر ليس كذلك، ولكن
فالعرض سهل على منفي
مجموعة من العروض المتطرفة مثل أننا سنوقفك
القتال الآن هو الذي نقول أنه سيلعب
المختطفين
عد، سوف تدخل هناك نوع من القوة
الدولية قوة دولية حتى مع التمثيل
بطريقة أو بأخرى، ولكننا نحن من نسيطر على القوة
الرهان الدولي الذي تقوله بصوت عالٍ
قول نعم لكل ما نشرناه اليوم
الدعوة لانتخابات نحن 171 رئيس أركان
رؤساء الموساد ورؤساء الشبيك والأبطال المتقاعدين
ونظيرهم في الأذرع الأمنية قمنا بتحريره
التلويح 0
من الناس
أنه في السنوات الثلاث الماضية تغلبوا على أمن
دولة إسرائيل على أكتافنا ونحن نقرأ
أعتقد أن الانتخابات تحظى بأغلبية قوية من الشعب في الانتخابات
أن هذه الحكومة ليست ملزمة بقيادتنا
في الحرب وأعتقد أنه كلما وصلنا إلى الانتخابات
الوقت مبكر، كما تعلمون
نحن جميعا